you think Joe Biden's taking bumps
before like a speech or something just
might he doesn't he's not going he
should he should what if that is his
hypeness right now come on man yeah
[Music]
yeah so there's a there's a video that
is circulating about you know how Joe
Biden has a perception that he's quite
handsy and quite he smells people why
does he keep smelling like there's like
a compilation of smelling girls only
with children usually smelling a lot of
kids that's like an old man thing
although he did smell I saw him smell
out of respect to him he SM smelled a
senator's wife or some [__] some like
judge or something he smelled like a
like a college graduate too I saw that
one oh he's getting older so he's he's
all across the map yeah he's gets his
nose in there diverse he's a big smeller
a big time smeller can't wait to be old
so there is a video that is
circulating and I want to get your guys
perspective on what and your thoughts
about this okay so I'm going to I'm
going to play this video perspectives
and thoughts oh man I like can you guys
all see this yeah okay wait I want to
see okay ready okay I like his smile
though I kind of like his smile and his
fond eyes so far he looks like a nice
little
Grandpa what'd he do kissed her on the
cheek he put something he put a pin a
sticker put a pin on the boob area okay
that's and then he kissed her and then
he kissed her that's his granddaughter
that's his granddaughter Natalie Biden
yeah so one more time okay video takes
forever but yeah here you go he goes
up she pins him pins
him and he pins he pins her mhm why does
he leave his hand there so long is that
what we're looking at so a lot of people
are I think it's sweet are saying that
he is touching a boo cuz he went what he
he's titty touching he went risk this if
I were to defend him it also just looks
like you would just left it on the the
chest it's also if if Anthony's facing
me right if Anthony's facing me and it
looks like this you can't really see
it's a bad angle right it's a bad angle
you can't see the finger squeeze so
check this out all the all the
right-wing media is going absolutely
Bonkers about this and saying like he's
touching titties and [__] but the the
this is what it actually looks like if
you have the right angle wow so he's so
he's doing this yeah looks up here and
then it looks like because they're
comfortable they just you know it's the
optical illusion of her black it looks
like a claw and he's using his strong
hand so yeah there's a lot of hay being
made wa clever wow cuz it looks like
he's like cupping the bra it really
looks like it really looks like he goes
won I feel like there's other videos but
in order to put a pin though don't you
need to lift the boob and then tie it on
correctly up yeah no okay well I don't
know the mechanics of a woman so why is
you like to cup the back of the butt so
if they scoot away I can just
oh away that's true cuz some people get
nervous around pins you know so they
might get jump and you don't want them
to be jumping when there's a pin out
they go wo with their butt so they get
pinned further forward yeah they go wo
and I go W and I just like you can just
control better front and back that so
people are are dunking on a all the
right wi usuals are doing that that's
crazy that that it's just this much and
then you can see that it's fine I mean I
think also it's his granddaughter so I
mean you know maybe they've just had
like a close connection since her really
really childish days you know that's
probably what it is isn't there some
kind of conspiracy about them too
journal from one of his huh Diaries or
something where they write talking about
the N Biden D diary where she say she
took showers with them yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's her right is that Natalie is
nothing like I said they're very close
it's her childhood that's what I'm
saying like you should bring that up
more I've heard that a couple times I
don't know the details is that a
conspiracy or is that like a that's a
for real thing it's a thing but I don't
know if like you know is the diary
verified and [__] I don't know bro like
blue check in context we don't know cuz
like it is normal for a grandpa to bathe
his granddaughter like yeah it's not
that abnormal yeah it's not completely
wild although I mean not when not when
they're old enough to
journal good point it's like okay good
point interesting yeah but as a toddler
yeah toddlers aren't usually journaling
like the Hun Biden laptop thing is real
right that's just a real thing that we
all know it's real now and the photos of
the hookers and the crack and all that a
lot of real stuff yep that's excusable
he was hanging dong in one of the
pictures wasn't he he was definitely the
slinging dick big time there's one where
he's sleeping with a crack pipe oh yeah
there's all kinds of stuff but that's
Hunter right yeah that's Hunter Hunter
there's one who was uh talking to a
[__] did you guys hear it he was
talking to like a I think it was like a
White House official of some sort and
he's talking like you can tell he's in a
state of pan Panic so he's like talking
to her on the other end okay yeah
whatever okay I'll do that whatever
whatever whatever and then she drops
some news that makes him like stress out
so he picks up a crack pipe and he goes
oh yeah and then the chick's like are
you smoking right now
yeah and I was like this guy's [__]
he
goes and I'm just like this is one of
the craziest videos bro crack smells
crazy dude it does it smells nuts he's
so comfortable that he was like life
streaming he doesn't give a f that it
was so crazy would you reach for a crack
pipe if you were stressed out maybe is
that what you were he probably needs a
crack pipe the [__] that he has to deal
with yeah yeah running all his dad's
accounts I would I don't know anything
about crack but I would imagine it would
have make you more anxious did you guys
see this I didn't even know
that Biden had a son until like way
later I just thought that he had like a
veteran son that passed away oh yeah
yeah yeah what is this this is Hunter
perhaps doing a bump of coke real quick
happens so fast though behind the oh
because he start wiping his nose out
that's you can't tell no that's the kind
of [__] man I bet if you're a politician
though cuz you he might have P been
picking a booger but the dumb thing is
the dumb thing is you don't even need
that video like he has other so many
clear earth videos yeah yeah he has a
dangling crackpipe from his [__]
lower lip like why he's vlogging his own
crack I don't understand why why he's
documenting himself continually people
just act like none of that stuff's real
just but I bet if you take a hit of
crack and you see yourself in the mirror
you're like damn I look good bro I got
to snap this real quick I got to [__]
remember it's funny cuz even even us
pointing out the laptop stuff and all
those photos like I'm not saying don't
let Biden be present over that just say
that shit's happening yeah just
acknowledge it just acknowledge your son
does crack it's fine I don't think in
that video he's like doing a bump of
coke because like when you not that I
know but when you're like you know
hitting a bullet or something like that
where you can actually you call it hit a
bullet he's never done it what's that
he's never done it but explain what a
bullet is okay so basically a bullet is
uh the contraption that holds like a
bump of coke and that's what you usually
do in a very quick or a key yeah it's
Scoops it up about the size of a key you
could twist it and then it shoots up
yeah so then you would take it how do
you know the exact size with their
fingers and stuff too seen very a lot of
documented go ahead and YouTube it oh is
that why guys have the fingernail I used
to have one it was it was lying green
plus if he if he really did Coke you
would have seen him go I didn't
yeah that's so true
[Laughter]
and you know oh
yeah that's so
accurate let's go sell some
cars you have time for a power this is
the video Anthony was watching so this
this is a this is a bullet so it really
looks like a bullet what is this Channel
right now you you have you have Coke in
the chamber on the bottom you flip it
upside down like Joe says so a small
amount goes into the head and it Scoops
it up yeah it Scoops it up and now it's
ready to
load and then you put it in your nose
and you push it and you inhale if you're
going to be a follow you got to quit
Coke I'm just knowledgeable about this
[__] like he was with feudal Japan you
know what I mean I didn't do Coke you
know that much about
Coke you know my theory about why people
like don't want to face the hunter Biden
stuff
is uh a lot of people I think proudly
voted for Biden sure yeah so I think for
most people like no one wants to admit
they made a mistake it's very hard for
people to do that just like Co and masks
no one wants to actually be like so
people were like so proud that they
voted for Biden and now all this
[__] comes out so no one wants to go
like oh [__] I [__] up and I voted for
the wrong family you know they're just
like I don't see it see that Biden was
the most popular president like ever
like like did you know that he had more
votes than Obama which is crazy like
more votes than Obama so it's either
that people absolutely loved them or
they hated Trump so much I think that
was it or a lot of like mail in ballots
just kind of appeared out of nowhere but
that's another theory there's another
yeah there's a whole lot of different
there's a whole lot of different
theories Obama was a [__] beast cuz
for me I'm like I can see Obama being
popular even if people didn't like him
he had a movement there's you can
clearly
see you can clearly see it you're not
going to wear Joe Biden on your shirt
like like I remember when those Obama
shirts came out everyone was wearing the
merch oh dude hell yeah although we used
to rocked some Joe Biden hats pretty
yeah we did we still have them here dude
imagine you got you got Joe Biden's face
on your shirt though and that silhouette
that's kind of tight now actually now
that you say it now that Nick the funny
guy endorsed it stop calling me funny
guy dude it makes me feel like you're
making fun of me think it's so there's
such a funny comparison where like
people refuse to admit the laptop [__]
is real because it puts their presidency
like choices at risk but like you can
like Ignition Remix and admit R Kelly's
guilty that's hilarious that's funny but
that song is fire I know and they and
they haven't taken it off of one car
they took it off a month they should
they shouldn't they brought it right
back on but it's like it shouldn't
affect that like it doesn't have to
affect that but like let's not be in
major denal just cuz someone has a crazy
ass son like okay whatever that's you
didn't vote him in office yeah look at
uh was it Tom Hank son be ring the nword
and [__] yeah ched Hanks I'll see fors
Gump too
yeah yeah I think what's weird is how
they're suppressing wait who's cooler
Joe uh Hunter Biden or I think the
weirdest thing is like we know it's like
there I actually think it makes him a
better president to be like yeah my son
has a drug problem how many of you guys
like he would be so much more relatable
said am I right yeah they're
crazy yeah that'll be tight yeah it's
just that the media like has to handhold
every little moment and act like shit's
not happening and and but that's the
thing you can't they can't get away with
it anymore cuz they're not the the only
Gatekeepers for all information now now
we're just laughing at them but stuff
like this right where they're like look
at that and they slow down the hand next
to Natalie Biden's boob and it's like
see now it all just seems like you're
taking weird shots when you have all
this other information just stay over
here maybe that's leaked from his team
though you know what I mean it's like
let's focus on the boob grab and not
think about let's show that he's still
got it be or they the fact that they
find cocaine in the White House during
his administration and then they just
give up looking for they gave up they
just go H we get I don't know [__]
crazy in the White House of all places
they're like we just don't know we see
is when you find cocaine right no I'm
just kidding you think Joe Biden's
taking bumps before like a speech or
something just he he doesn't he's not
going W he should he should what if that
that is his hypeness right now come on
man yeah yeah yeah dude if we saw Joe
Biden come out and just deliver A
[__] massive sick ass speech and he
was fired up we'd be looking at but what
if that is his fired up what if his
normal's this yeah yep and then he takes
a bump he's like you see um oh that's
his normal that's his hype it would
maybe be the most punk rock moment in
history if Joe Biden gave a state of the
union and then sprinkle cocaine on on
the podium and just [__] cranked it
yeah letter her full just [__] rips
his shirt open yeah dude in front of
everybody and then right off of
Natalie's tit dude cuz you know what
happened the next day like bench was
like can I have a president who was
doing cocaine yeah yeah yeah yeah we
would all be able to show running that
clip and [__] laughing our asses off
yeah that's funny he's such a hall
monitor or he'll just play the video of
Hunter Biden doing crack and he's like
that's still my
boy just lean into it stand by your son
by your sons they need our help more
than ever that'd be tight that would I'd
rally bro yeah is what it is make the
most of it that's his Coalition that's
the Biden Coalition that's how he builds
the mov father's protecting their son
and is it so bad I mean if they're
getting stuff done yeah right like like
they're making the country way better if
you're hitting Major League home runs I
don't care what you're
taking I haven't met one person who's
not like dude the country is going so
well yeah D it's going great if you're
making deals you know signing babies bro
[__] do a couple bombs they're
crushing just they're just Crushers
really